yeah come on in JJ welcome yeah of
course of course shake my hand
how's it go man good how you feeling is
this is that right are you on are you on
West Coast time is just specifically
early right there I'm we're live on the
air by the way so don't say anything
that I promise you I'm okay that you
would not broadcast I'm all good I've
know I've been on East Coast for a
couple weeks
oh cool what do you don't any are you
doing the with the play or no we're uh
we're in Maine for uh for July oh I see
I see this one's a Detroit by the way
did you how was Detroit best was it oh
my god everybody talk [ __ ] about Detroit
who does a lot like the general
consensus no no no Detroit rocks what
I've heard that too I guess I heard
amazing Detroit Rock City why do you
like Detroit why'd you like Detroit so
much Motor City yeah why don't I like to
try so much uh people are awesome but
they're making I what language can I use
you can use whatever language you want
to use okay they're making amazing stuff
yeah they're making a some credible [ __ ]
there's a set is like an energy in that
city that they are just there they're
doing stuff they're making things and it
says crazy thing of like you see one
block and the buildings are in just
complete disrepair yeah
and the next block you see this
unbelievably gorgeous feel something's
moving in a way that I don't think you
necessarily feel in New York for Ella
it's also more I find Detroit to be one
of the more American cities like you
feel that that's an American city and
maybe it's because it's right in the
middle like it's not quite rural but
it's not this sort of urban thing that
LA or New York is I agree it was a very
unique vibe and I'd never been there
before and the food was incredible the
music was great
watching people make stuff the industry
of it yeah it's still alive and you can
actually feel the heartbeat of the city
when you're there it's very cool my
grandparents lived in Detroit so I spent
a long time as a kid there what they do
um my grant
my grandma stayed home but my
grandfather was like at first he was a
TV repairman
when he was younger but then he just
became like he I think he just did shady
[ __ ] like he owned a couple I think he
owned a couple buildings but I don't
know where he would get money to own
buildings from so he would go in and and
act as super for a couple buildings and
he he's a sniper from one day at a time
yeah just he just only did four yeah I'm
sure he just always had love games going
on but they didn't live in a nice area
of Detroit so what I wasn't I didn't see
this
but Amazings and there are some een the
thing is that especially now that it has
gone through this sort of you know
decline and now it's kind of coming back
you see a building and from the outside
it looks like it's just this decaying
thing and you walk inside and it is the
most glorious mural you'll ever see and
you know that building is going to be
redone and rebuilt and you know they're
like skyscrapers that are you know on
sale for three million dollars right but
then it's like 150 million dollars to
you know refurbish them and bring them
back and you know so it's like this is
it but there it's happening now it is
happening and it's looking incredible
yeah yeah I mean I'd love to see a man
come back it's a city like it's not so I
loved do you when you see stuff like
that like you kind of walk around
constantly being inspired because I feel
like where you're at especially after
you know the play that goes wrong is now
on Broadway and that's really a
performance aside the fact that it got
it's getting the attention it's getting
is a lot to to you when you realize that
you have that kind of power to get eyes
on something that deserves to have eyes
on it do you feel like oh my god I can I
can just do stuff all the time well I
never think of anything that way I think
of it like oh that is cool and I really
love that either idea or that that you
know the story or the world of it in the
case of the play that goes wrong I saw
the play in London
it just it killed me it was so funny I
hadn't laughed that hard in ages the
audience was going crazy it just felt
like you know this has to go to Broadway
obviously so I was just asking when it
was going and they were like oh we're
just still getting it up and running
here and I was like really well if you
ever want help if I can help out in any
way you know let me know and it was just
out of liking it
wasn't like you know I didn't I didn't
think nor do I that my association with
it means much but what I what I do feel
is that you know if you can be part of
bringing something that matters or that
touches you to other people then you
should do it right so that was my role
but it's kind of amazing that you got
into a place now where you can that can
happen like you you because you wanted
people to see this thing it's hard
Broadway well I honestly I think that
what I thought it was a fully-formed
thing that was inevitably going to get
there anyway right and it was more of a
selfish interest to jump in and try and
be part of it right to jump on this now
because there's going to be big
regardless so let me let me be a guy it
wasn't like I looked at it and thought
you know okay this is this is the best
you know way to make a profit I wasn't
thinking about the money if I thought
you know the money and the success of
something you know whether it does box
office is always works itself out
meaning it's like that cannot ever be
the the driver but what I did feel was
if everyone including myself is laughing
this hard this it's just it's a
universal thing which by the way the
play has proven itself to be is it's in
a number of countries you know
translated to multiple languages it's
there's a universality because it's a
very physical comedy
yeah and it's fun too you know you see
ten-year-old kids you see you know a
hundred and fifty year old nothing you
know you see you see all people you see
young people it's an amazing thing to
watch people react to this and it also
works because like you go to a play
hoping that bad things happen like you
want to see somebody that got a line and
you want to see something because that's
the whole the whole reason that live has
an attraction to it you know it's
because something unpredictable can
happen well every time there's a
performance you get a report if you're
involved in the play of like you know
when at the curtain go up exactly how
long the acts were you know what was the
audience reaction and everything and the
other night one of the actresses
literally in the middle of the play got
sick and had to step out at halftime and
be replaced by the understudy for the
second half which you know and then I I
wish I'd been there because I don't know
if the audience is essa' Sara Lee knew
that that was not part of the play right
however they didn't either
I mean if it's end is amazing I would
try to pass off as a person what is that
credit it is such a physical play yeah
and there's so much that sort of old
sort of silent movie ish kind of
physical stuff that it's it's
unbelievable looking backstage what has
to go right for it to be the play that
goes wrong right it's an amazingly
choreographed very precise performance
and these people who created it with me
what's so lucky is we have the original
cast members that were the creators of
the play originated the roles on
Broadway now and they're there for about
another month yeah but watching them
work together is kind of a brilliant
thing it's also amazing because like in
a world that love CGI and seven movies
that you've been in to watch a play have
this much stuff like you have to
understand if you don't see this play
you'll see what I'm talking about
people have to be standing in the exact
right spot at the exact right time like
the choreography has to be just so
because the sets falling down and this
thing is and people are either going to
get hurt or the comedy is going the
timing is going to get lost it so
clearly doesn't go exactly right you
remind me a few years ago I went to UCLA
and they were showing a old Harold Lloyd
black-and-white you know uh comedy and
he was a silent movie performer and just
this brilliant guy like Buster Keaton
Chaplin style and there was this one
movie called safety last and he's
climbing up the side of this building
and and the audience there are a
thousand people in the audience it's a
big place we're screaming watching him
nearly slip and fall and keep climbing
up this clock tower and it was because
people watching knew it had to be real
because it was in 1917 or something
movie that there was no CGI then right
but people were screaming in the
audience in a way that they never scream
at movies yeah watching a near-miss and
there's something to what you're saying
the play that goes wrong is that same
thing of there's stuff physically
happening in front of you that is sort
of undeniably you know it's so
timing-dependent it's so tricky and in
some cases potentially very dangerous if
they don't totally do their job right do
you take that back when you start when
you go back you see this play and then
and then you help get it to Broadway you
go back to moviemaking do you take any
of that with you like I want more
that I think you take f ing ball I think
you take everything that you experience
that feels like oh that works with you
in some way and and look it's hard not
to see that and be inspired in just in
terms of the the irreverence of it it is
such a silly fun you know night at the
theater and I feel like watching people
react the way they do to it it does make
me feel like oh comedy just film TV you
know stage doesn't matter is just it's
especially in this moment it is so
valuable to get to go somewhere and just
have a completely like silly fun you
know laugh yeah that's what the play
that goes wrong but yeah the is there
any is it do you have a project that
like you did because you've done so much
now do you have a project that you
thought it got so big early on that this
is going to be it like this this one is
going to be it for me and I don't know
if I'm going to be able because a lot of
people do that right they have a
breakout whether it's whether it's the
series whether it's Star Trek whether
it's something that got big to the point
where you were like this is what I may
not be able to escape from I mean almost
like if an actor is plays a character
where it's like that's the thing they
become exactly um I feel you know I've
had on a number of occasions situations
where I was working in something that
you know I felt like it can't get more
either more intense or more kind of
attention or sort of more focus or
whatever then yeah what my first movie
was a that I directed was a mission
impossible 3 was the you know big Tom
Cruise starring thing you know there was
no way when I was doing that that I
could imagine I thought this is you know
the biggest star in the world it was
overwhelming and so that the terror of
taking that on and working on that movie
I thought well it can't get more intense
than strangely doing the Star Trek movie
it was it felt more more intense and and
a little bit more stressful bright
because there was no Tom Cruise like
there was the cast was an extraordinary
cast but none of them were sort of you
know in a lot of the more unknown at the
time
and so sort of like there was no one to
look to to go you know all right we'll
work kind of in this thing together and
you've done it a million times like Tom
had so that was really stressful and it
also becomes like now the biggest name
attached first on Star Trek itself is no
Tom Cruise right like that name and the
fact that you're rebooting the franchise
but now JJ Abrams is the name
well tattooed the Saint like if that had
gone wrong they'd say if Mission
Impossible had gone wrong at that point
they might have blamed it on Tom Cruise
but if Star Trek goes wrong right you're
then it's me yeah so there was there was
that and then of course the Star Wars it
was it was it was just preposterous
because it was just you know it but I
say in each of those situations I got to
be part of some pre-existing thing that
was bigger than all of us and bigger
than me and and with Star Wars of course
it's there is nothing more you know
there's nothing bigger than that as a
sort of as a franchise yeah but it was
really fun to be part of it was that
decision like to do Star Wars because
again you don't want to be pigeonholed
but at the same time this is like a
massive opportunity you did Star Trek it
was successful you don't want this one
to not be it's a risk
the decision was frankly uh it was a
tough one and you know there's a longer
answer to it but the short answer was it
was a frightening one but like you said
I knew I would never get this kind of a
shot again and it just it my wife said
to me I remember when we were talking
about it and should we do it should we
not we'd have this plan everything and
she just said that this is one of those
things that you will regret not doing
forever if you say no to this and and so
you should really think about it you
know and and Kathy Kennedy uh and you
know Larry Kasdan and the group of
people that I was lucky enough to work
with they were just extraordinary so I
felt incredibly a you know I was in
great company another one though where
you don't have I mean the the returning
characters are kind of secret so you
don't you don't have a name like you
don't have a Tom Cruise in that movie to
rely on it's just back to with Star Wars
yeah well we had Harrison we had we have
a does I mean know that you weren't
there what they did in the movie with
with secret before it came out and it
was also like not contingent on them you
know what I mean well I mean I do think
that the audience's knowing that you
know that Carrie Fisher and Mark Hamill
and Harrison were were returning that
that was a you know an enormous draw and
and and you know they became as iconic
as the franchise did but you know it's
something I loved so much and cared
about so much that working on it was
there was the added sort of burden I
mean it was also kind of a gift but it
was a burden of having to be playing
with and working on something that that
mattered so much to myself as well as
the you know the incredible fan base so
it was the the the pressure on everyone
I think was vaguely unbearable but but
but also but we also I think had a great
time working on it right and and also I
think that part of having the original
cast come back is that's a cosign right
like we're all sure they're all there
this universe is returning yes if it is
it more difficult to bring back Star
Trek in the sense that it hasn't it
hadn't really been messed with recently
or Star Wars because it had been and it
hadn't gone well but honestly the the
it's funny when you ask you know people
of various generations what their
favorite Star Wars movie is you get
different answers like you know there
are a lot of people for whom the
prequels are their favorite Star Wars
really and and there are people of
course who love the original series
because that was theirs and and now
there's a whole new series and and I
think that you know you will find
different answers probably every time
and that's the genius of what George
created I think it's something that that
you know will last and last and take on
different sort of forms and have people
sort of rooting for and relating to
different different generations of that
story but the the Star Trek versus Star
Wars thing there so there it's a hard
you know they're not apples apples
there's such
print things so there are a lot of
variables in each and so it's difficult
to sort of quantify yeah
they both have the word star they do
they both have obsessive fan bases and
they're both sci-fi and that's kind of
yeah and right and I have to say you
know I feel like they had their own
specific immunity challenges but but
getting to work on either of them
frankly I feel really lucky to have been
involved in or to be involved in any
number of these of these things that any
one of them in their own way if you had
told me when I was a kid I get to be
part of I would not have believed you
which is why the initial question of
like did you ever think one would be the
one because when you look at everything
you've done it is what you think like
you think one of these projects that you
do would be what you get to do the fact
that you've gotten to do so much is
incredible but but I mean I don't know
don't you don't you like look at what
you do like everything you're doing
you're just sort of doing that thing I
you don't look for me outside in and go
you know I just I just feel like every
project I remember working on Felicity
this TV show that I did with that reads
like we worked on that show and it was
that at the time felt like it does not
get bigger than this but I was like
there was a huge show but I mean at the
time it was like it was it and and for
us yeah how can we work this is it if it
this is it fine we've got to do this so
every step of the way there's there's
something I don't think comparing it is
I know I will never be involved in
anything that is as big a star wars
there's no way it Star Wars is bigger
than anything anyone you know yeah but
it's it just it's not the thing I don't
think about the scale I just think about
like what's the master I'm serving what
is a story to tell right now and I feel
lucky to have been involved in any of it
yeah and that's probably the way to
survive it too right it's just to
realize like this is the task at hand
take a deep breath I can do this and
then you just do it I remember in 1990 I
was a writer on a movie called regarding
Henry that Mike Nichols directed and
actually Harrison Ford started and I was
I was on the set I was 23 24 something
and
I'm I'm on the set of this but we're in
the editing room Sam Osteen who was this
amazing editor I remember he was joking
with me that it's uh he was he said me
better late than early meaning it's
better to peek in your career late of
courting like that then too early
because I was just you know he was he
was sort of laughing at me but the idea
was that like how as a as a 20 I think
it's 24 at the time 24-year old writer
you know working on my movie that Mike
Nichols is directing that Harrison Ford
is starring in the editor was basically
saying if it it's over for you like and
he was right yeah like what there was
nothing out what else was I going to do
yeah as you know a writer that was it
and so I've felt that again and again
and again at every step of my career
like this it can't get more lucky right
then to get to work on this and the fact
that it's happened a few times is really
preposterous DUI when you were younger
because I'm sure you don't do it now but
when you were younger did you worry
about maintaining momentum if that makes
sense I think like what because I don't
think about it so much now but I know
when I was younger and something good
would happen
half of me would be enjoying this good
thing happening and working on it and
the other half of me would be like okay
how do I make sure I keep going forward
keep going forward keep going for and
that's a big pressure on me it's like my
I felt that but in a slightly different
way my feeling was more like I get I
always feel like there's a sense of
needing to work on something next but
it's not like a again and outside in
like I need to keep sort of career
momentum going it's more like I have
this opportunity right now to sort of
parlay this into now sometimes that
means parlaying this thing into
something that's really good and better
and deeper and working on that thing but
for example with TV shows you know when
I worked on Felicity I ended up leaving
Felicity as the sort of showrunner after
a couple years to do the show it was
called alias and I was on that show for
a couple years then I ended up leaving
that show to work on this show lost that
I did with Jamie
Lindelof by the way I loved it like
you're naming hugely successful shows
but being like it's the show called
alias though this show called lost like
we all know the show there are a lot of
people
I'm telling you I cuz there I've made
the mistake sometimes of saying you know
when I was doing aliased and you know I
was like what
really yeah you never know Jesus sighs I
don't do not presumed anyone's heard of
anything yet but when you could in for
an interview think they did least know
well I know who you are like a little I
apologize to anyone who's listening but
no but this exhibition is that every
time I've worked on on something I've I
can't help myself to think you know what
is the what is the next project and
maybe it's just restlessness maybe it's
that you know I I don't know if I would
have the patience to sit on you know in
one place and do like when I look at
what Matthew you know Weiner did with
Mad Men yep like and you know look at
what certainly what Damon and and
Carlton did was lost you know they were
there for six years working on that show
you know creating this you know
incredible deep mythological tapestry of
emotion and character and and that was
something I don't know if I would be
able to do working on a film for a
couple years like a folk focused thing I
love that and and I know I can do that
but it might just be in my nature to you
know always be sort of saying okay
what's the next thing to get to me
excited and you'd like to know there's
an end there's a beginning middle end
like they're like this film will be done
being made and then I can do the next
thing I I just I I just like there are
you know it's a little bit like someone
who's sort of in their you know their
job and feels like after a few years I'm
getting a little bit Restless yet so
it's not unlike a thing that I think is
fairly common yeah but then I look at
someone like Damon and you know or like
I said with with Mad Men there a few
obvious examples and I just I'm so in
awe of the ability and discipline to
focus and work on one thing consistently
for the run of the series right just so
you can have your hands on the whole bio
so in that respect then is it fairly
easy for you to when you have your hands
only on something like it like in a
director role and then for the sequel or
whatever which you've done before end up
as a producer so it's you're still hands
on but not quite as intimately is that
easy for you because you you want to
move on to something else or is it
difficult to give that up you know it
there's a sometimes a bittersweet
feeling when you watch someone else like
when we were doing the last Star Trek
movie and Justin Lin was directing on
the one hand it was really fun to watch
what he was doing and how he did it and
his process and his people and he was
you know he's an excellent guy and you
know great filmmaker so it was sort of
fun to watch and at the same time there
was there these pangs of missing working
personally with that that cast or you
know being involved in the story and
those characters in a directorial way
but again it's it's a it's something
that I think is it's such a lucky
problem to have to be watching someone
going off and directing Daisy Ridley and
John boyega and Oscar Isaac uh you know
in something and feeling like oh you
know I really miss those but it's like
you know yeah you know whom I can
complain to about this it's like you
know I got to be involved in this thing
at all and now I'm watching a great
filmmaker right Ryan take on the next
step it's like it's it may be
bittersweet but it's like it's it's
mostly sweet you're logically it you
logically know you can't complain about
it but on some level it's like ah yeah
that was fun yes yeah yeah and I'm also
again uh I think if you focus on
gratitude and you you just you know it's
hard to burn anyone who got to be
involved in these amazing worlds uh you
know who's complaining because they're
not involved in all of the yes as like
well screw you know when did you when
did you start focusing more on gratitude
more as opposed to whatever lately just
during this interview I was like did you
just figure it out like and we're
talking like what like why am I not more
grateful because that's another thing I
think that when I mean and I only speak
from my own experience
but I guess other people I've talked to
it's difficult
maybe when you're young but also when
you haven't had as much success to find
that gratitude for the little things
when you look at other people and say oh
man like I should be doing that or off I
was a little more of that and I think
that that it becomes easier to find
gratitude when you've got your own
success but the irony is a lot of times
people who have achieved a certain
success look back on the earlier days as
those are the days that they're actually
the most grateful for totally and and so
I think in a way that there's never a
bad moment to start being grateful for
what you are and what you've got and I
think that it's a little bit like when
I'm working on something and there's
some problem and in retrospect they're
always with few exceptions there are
always things that that seem petty later
but when you're working on a project and
there's this massive at the moment
massive dilemma about what you're going
to do or how you going to make something
work better or how to fix the problem
and you know - for me I just stop and
think this is the problem I get to have
you know like that's a very lucky are
you able to do that though are you able
to in the middle of 500 to do it yeah
because in my head because it just you
know it sort of helps me kind of take a
breath and then it opens it creates
enough space to help find the answer
obviously in life and things that are
sort of real and true and family and
relationship I mean those are more
complex and difficult of course but I
just think you know even in those
situations it's just to try and find the
you know the the you know if if if
you're if you focus on gratitude right
it sort of gives you a sense of it for
me at least it helps me breathe that
helps me sort of find a kind of level
place to try and solve the problems very
very healthy it's an it's a good way to
solve problems it's not something that
you see that many people able to match
did you get there with a therapist or
did you get there on your own
my wife is someone who she's this she's
got this incredible sort of
like compass of what what what's
important yeah and she's someone who I
think without her I wouldn't be as sort
of aware of this but she really helps me
see that that side of things but and and
she you know we we do this thing with
our kids we do our at night we're having
dinner which is when typically dinners
at night yeah generally yeah I mean
depends were in the world obviously
right right all right
we at least time zones and things yeah
yeah so we have dinner tonight
but we hold hands we do our thankful we
just say what we're thankful for
from the day and it's just this little
thing that that we do and it sort of
becomes a habit to think about that
that's that's and that's actually as
opposed to like people and I'm not
jumping on anybody or putting words in
your mouth but like saying grace or
praying before meal is is one thing but
when you are actually citing specific
things yeah in your life that you're
thankful for I feel like that is that is
it more of a concrete example of like
this is and it's sort of in a way more
become sort of somewhat the religion of
the family is for us because it's a I'm
a you know I'm a I'm Jewish my wife's
Catholic our kids are confused it's like
you know we have and and so the idea of
like just going around talking about you
know what we're grateful for from the
day even if it's a 30-second kind of go
around of what everyone you know did
it's just it's a it's a kind of leveling
thing to do it helps how old are your
kids we have a 19 year old son 17 year
old daughter and an 11 year old son so
they're very are they fans of what you
do I think that there's some what fans
of things some of the things they've
seen they haven't seen everything and
you know we we haven't we're not the
kind of family likes deserve you know
let's sit down and watch the stuff that
you know data today you know and and
just as we don't you don't bring home
the dailies before dinner I know but we
my my our oldest son is interested in
film our daughters a songwriter and our
youngest is an athlete they're focused
on their stuff and they know what dad
does and you know they they know what
mom does but you know Katie works with
me at bad robot and but they don't
really they're kids who got to have
their own stuff and so I think that they
appreciate some of the you know they
never went to a premiere until the Star
Wars movie you know they like we kept
them from that stuff but then the weird
thing can be they'll go to school and
like someone will tell them about
something that is going on that they
haven't necessarily seen or heard about
because we don't you know bring it home
we don't bring out yeah yeah that makes
sense
did you try to when you're raising them
is like little little kids did you try
to get in them into the stuff that you
geeked out about because I guy I'm like
a wrestling the biggest wrestling nerd
of all time and so we just we have a
four-month-old right and so I'm trying
to figure out like what is my strategy
is it to get them in front of wrestling
now and just have osmosis kick in or is
it to just act like it's not happening
because I don't have one can we have one
kid you what I have found I think Katie
and I both is that that our kids are
born who they are you can influence them
somewhat you can you know expose them to
various things and they are who they are
man in a way I cannot believe and you
can have so you're like looking in like
where did you pick up on this sometimes
yeah you know but there are like you
know you can have I think a dozen kids
in the same house and and each one's
going to have their own you know
interest I it'll be interesting to see
if your kid ends up becoming a wrestling
fanatic like you but but the truth is
that there's you know you can't help but
expose your kids or the things you love
and if if classical music is your thing
that's what they're going to be
listening to you know until they can put
the headphones on you choose listen to
their own stuff yeah but I do think that
a you know when I watch our 11 year old
you know kick ass on you know the soccer
pitch or or I watch our daughter you
know write a song or our you know oldest
kid you know paint something it's like I
I can go oh that thing they got from
Katie you know that thing they kind of
got from me that's gonna go but it's the
best thing and this is what you'll find
when your kid old enough sort of body
slams you and as you know is that they
get back
and you know then you are so quickly
right at whatever you happen to love and
suddenly no more and do more and you
know and it's watching it's not there's
never been anything more joyous than
being left in the dust by our kids like
watching them kind of do their thing as
well as they know they do their thing
unless you realize I'm a complete
[ __ ] and just get competitive
immediately with this five that rolls up
yeah what a dick
I was already waiting when you were like
you know they become who they're going
to become regardless I was already in my
head I'm like how great if uni comes
Ashish mock I don't have to feel it
that's not me but I am that's sort of
actually that's a good way to look at it
- yeah but but I do think that like our
egos would you know allow us to believe
that we have this influence and we are
shaping these the truth is they are that
kind of shaped it is getting bigger and
the shape gets bigger right but they are
their personalities you know I think you
can probably trace unless there's some
really specific
you know incident that changes them in
some profound you know way but they seem
to be trackable you know Frank from
birth basically and then I think my kids
bipolar cuz he cries all the time let's
go a lot of people have questions for
you JJ Oh JJ Abrams is here and we go to
PJ in New Jersey what's up PJ hey guys
what's up longtime listener huge fan at
JJ I gotta say I'm a huge fan of your
work
kind thank you the world star wars all
that even Star Trek I wasn't I didn't
even watch the TV show and I watched the
movie and it just caught my interest no
I was something to his credit I was the
same way I could care I could not care
less about Star Trek The Next Generation
none of it did not care and I went and
saw the movie just because it was a big
movie and I liked seeing movies loved it
and I went and made me interested in the
sequels and the light now that's very
sweet yeah thank you I I'm very grateful
that's it but my question was how do you
feel when like say South Park portrayed
you is rewriting the star-spangled
banner okay again
I don't know it is Matt Stone and Trey
Parker go up to you and like hey man
we're going to protect you they just
kind of like throw it up I don't
first of all I am such a fan of theirs
and have so loved what they've done over
the years that there is no way I can
imagine I guess someone seeing
themselves made fun of on that show and
and getting angry and taking it
personally or something to me it is to
be mocked by those brilliant guys is the
absolute greatest compliment so to me it
just it makes me laugh and I'm like I'm
embarrassed in a way only cuz it's like
oh my god I can't even believe they're
wasting our time on this but the fact
that they do it they are so funny and
there's nothing but gratitude frankly to
go back to the term that I feel when I
when I watch them you know do their
thing whoever they're mocking I just
think those guys are Bryant I would
probably feel the same way I'd go to the
dinner table and say I'm thankful that
last night they they say kick the [ __ ]
out of me on South Park I I loved it but
it's almost like you know if you go to a
you know back when like the great Don
Rickles right was the obvious thing if
you go to see his show and he he you
know he points at you when he starts he
does two minutes on you like you cannot
be an [ __ ] and and say that that's
insulting right word it is the it is the
it is the honor of a lifetime yeah
to have Don Rickles two minutes on you
like right for me that you know Matt and
Trey though that falls in that category
thanks buddy no problem thanks yes
dude what do you think about that that
the remake stigma I feel like you have
obviously proven the remakes and reboots
and and and bringing back franchises can
be done well and successfully but there
are people who just kind of a lot of
people who generalize and put down the
idea of remaking a rebooting altogether
first of all I think there is generally
a sense of a bit of fatigue of the kind
of programmed nature of what movies have
become whereas with TV there's so much
stuff that's happening that is you know
groundbreaking and original and so that
it there's a weird movies to become TV
and TV become movies I think that
they're always the exceptions so when
you see something like war the Planet of
the Apes which is so well done and yet
emotional so beautiful you go oh well
you know fantastic keep it coming right
but I think generally speaking there's a
thing of like oh my god like another you
know sequel of that thing that was
already a reboot you know I get that
feeling and I know I'm as responsible as
anyone for these things so I may be more
allergic to it than most people but I do
feel like you know there's something
thrilling when you see something like
you know get out or baby driver or split
or you know the movies that that are you
know original stories being told you
know even Dunkirk I mean obviously this
is a historical you know drama but but
you know you see a movie that is not
based on something that had someone with
a cape right it's just you know it's
something I think is refreshing and I
hope and believe that Hollywood will you
know continue to go in that direction as
well I love that aside from Dunkirk not
the other movies that you just mentioned
specifically because I'm like a huge fan
of fairly low-budget by high-concept
done right here and I feel like the
backlash to all the sort of big-budget
movies has been like okay what can we
get done for a little bit of money and
they're finding more and more people
that can do high concept stuff which is
like the funnest I can watch there's
also you know in those movies there's
something you can sort of feel the
modesty yeah of them and it's like a
turn-on because you go oh it's not some
massive corporate decision it's like
people who clearly busted their ass and
we had to sort of be cleverer than they
were reliant on the axe the crutch of
the inside feel people's hands on it yes
yeah so I think that you know like there
are a lot of examples but you know when
you see get out it is it is as emotional
as surprising as funny as scary as
anything that costs literally a hundred
times at yeah but that movie caused so
little and the result is you know I
think you know it speaks for itself so
yeah I'm very excited about that realm
of moving
we go to Reno in Tennessee Reno you're
on with JJ Abrams right what's going on
say on somebody hello
ah hey I got a question for JJ Oh me and
my lady just got done a binge watching
the show a person of interest
oh and it's like JJ Abrams on it every
time I'm like ain't that the dude that
did Star Wars I was wondering I guess
you're right about the other I said some
people do not know yeah well I'm not
into sci-fi so you know either way but I
was wondering is there going to be maybe
a reboot a comeback a spin-off of that
show because we was really invested in
that show and when did it talk bless you
thank you for for watching really
appreciated the the creator of that
showed Jonah Nolan is now working with
his wife Lisa joy running this show that
we're doing called Westworld and so his
focus is part of that one to focus is on
on that and though I would love there to
be a continued continuing story of a
person of interest my guess is that at
least for the moment
until someone reboots it someone else
Mike my guess is that it's it sadly
ended where it did but there were a lot
there's a lot more story that they
wanted to to tell but at a certain point
the apparently show's end right that
happened yes that does happen but like
you - thank you Colton in New Mexico
goodbye cause I hear it yeah I hear what
you're saying it happens all the time
so you west world was an interesting one
because West world is one of those that
is not low-budget at all and it's like
if it doesn't work like that's a big
risk for HBO to take do you feel that
when they're taking it it's funny West
world is something HBO has been
incredible and the obvious
investment financially uh that they've
made in that but but also you know it's
this is a big show yeah in every
direction and the the beauty of the
collaboration with them is that they've
got the resources not you know that they
can't spend I'm sure you know they can't
burn money but these are people who who
get the idea of doing something that
ultimately is a sort of in terms of
Westworld a sort of wonderfully pulp
idea but if you do something like that
you know Triple A which is how Jonah and
Lisa pitched it and the vision that that
they have for this show the cast that
they've assembled the you know the
script they've written the episodes that
they've they've produced it's it really
is and with what's coming up especially
with next season there's something so
exciting about it and of course everyone
feels like it's their money meaning we
don't go into a project and feel like
you know well let's just see what I you
know this is a very you know we're
asking for what is needed because we
think if done right it could it could be
a very special yea show and and I think
that the Joan and Lisa had delivered on
everything that they promised how do you
do with criticism the are you able to
how do you think I don't take it well
are you able to let it bounce off you at
this point or do you do you dwell on it
too much I mean I feel like I'm probably
more critical on myself than anyone
could be on me except maybe Katie - it's
not because you know it's like when when
you when you're married to someone you
really love and you know they're
critical it's like it's a that's the
voice but I do feel like you know it is
so important to be critical and it's so
important to be criticized like the the
scary thing is is ever being in a place
where you know you don't want to listen
or that you're so hurt by criticism that
you don't take it in I think that the
only way you get better is hearing
people you know give you [ __ ] for stuff
that didn't really work right as it
needed to and by the way they're right
like anyone who doesn't like something
who voices it is right yes there are
haters and there are trolls and there
did it you know there's that side of it
but you know anyone's opinion you can't
just go oh you know she liked it you
know she's writing but she didn't like
it she's wrong yeah I have to go well
the person who didn't like it is as
correct as the person who did and as
long as you appreciate you're never
going to please everyone and as long as
you appreciate that you know you're just
trying to do the best you can and you're
open to people telling you it could be
better you have a shot at actually you
know doing decent work how on earth did
you guys manage to keep all these Star
Wars secrets like it boggles my mind
that the stuff that happens in Star Wars
is kept see like you guys keep secrets
better than the government does
everything else leaks and nothing from
Star Wars leaks you know Kathy Kennedy
wants a tight ship yeah actually just
does man yeah it's gotta be a lot of a
I'm guessing physical intimidation
that's my guess she also threatens
people yeah so I thought